jon jones finishes his fight did you see
what do you say
oh man that is so good now we're sending
this message
to our dear friend john jones bones what
do you say that's alhamdulillah he said
the manager at the gym if he really say
that and he said to me what else would
you say if you had a one-on-one
conversation with jon jones
and we're doing this out of the love
who's he praying to the god
to his creator he was screaming allah
allah
in his language
jon jones listen to this this is
profound listen listen
back in the days the black people was
the rulers there was the kings and the
queens they have a big beautiful history
[Music]
how you guys doing guess who's with me
look at that you remember our brother
ali kedakov
last time we did a program i was on
florida
and we talked about his story being a
professional fighter you guys can check
out that show i have it in the
description below if you haven't watched
it bring you up to speed a little bit so
we'll be talking about
what people who are involved in mma
they like watching these ufc we'll talk
a little bit about that we'll talk about
purpose
and we'll talk about some other things
but how you been overall brother
everything's good everything's good in
this part of the world yeah yeah
so last time when we did the show how
was things what kind of response did you
get
a lot of people actually contacted me
from my country they was
motivated you know and happy because we
see a lot of good stuff over there for
muslims
because the things you know they need to
hear some people and especially they've
translated to the russian language
translated yeah so this was
awesome you see you see what i'm saying
because you you have a good following
also from your from your fighting days
right so people are still turning in you
people from
you're very well known and um uh what
in russia you know russia
so look at that you said that they were
very motivated just by now some some
good words that you said you see how you
awaken some of the things because you
got
so many distractions you got so much
negativity you got so many
stds spiritually transmitted diseases
right and it's affecting the hearts now
here you come along
someone a public figure you have you
know a voice a platform
and you hit it out there and awakens the
good exactly it is important because we
see what job
muhammad ali did back in the days you
know i was in philadelphia this was
amazing i see so many brothers and
sisters over there
you know this from his speech you know
the words as a power man he says
you can bring so much good i'll speak
the truth you know because the people
feed it in
from the media they see all this garbage
over there you know and they have no
knowledge about the religion or the
muslims
so they start judging when they actually
interact with you and talk to you
you know i mean you open the new world
for them yeah muslims don't even
know we believe in uh jesus is a prophet
peace be upon him you know what i mean
that's deep and you shared a story if
you can share for our audience that
uh one time you met a a christian
uh pastor and you had a chance to talk
to her
yeah i talked to her you know and she
was a pastor from brazil she come to
give the big lecture over here she was a
scholar christian scholar
and i asked a simple question i said can
i ask you a question
so i'm not even a student i know my
religion just a little bit
and i asked i said where the fundamental
or in your religion is
trinity right you say right say this is
the three gods and one and
all these kind of confusing things i say
can you explain this to me so she starts
explaining can i tell her okay
i can ask you one question so yes do you
follow the ten commandments do you
believe in them she said yes
i said what the first commandment says
the first comment says the god is only
one
i said didn't this break the old the
trinity mythology
and she got confused because she cannot
explain from before
then i go to the second commandment when
i tell them about i i
worship the idols i say so how it is if
the
bible says in second commandment do not
worship the idols do not draw the
pictures
not it would above meaning the moon the
stars the sun the birds not even one uh
on the bottom meaning the fishes the
animals the human beings and anything
else
so the bible telling you do not do this
while you're doing this so my main
question to her was do you follow the
bible
and the teachings of jesus christ or you
follow the church
because it seems you follow the church
teachings you know about innovation
completely
what like jesus never wore the cross
jesus
never eat the pork he was circumcised he
was wearing the long taupe
you know what the muslim these days the
arabs dressing
he was having a long beard you know and
have
even a scripture and matthew i don't
remember what scripture this is in
matthew i think 20
26 39 yeah when he prostrate yeah you
know what i mean
the way we pray yeah and he went a
little further
and he fell on his face and prayed to
himself
who's he praying to the god to his
creator yeah and when he
was teaching the people how to pray when
he raised
he what we do we call this dua the
prayer to the god
almighty and he says what he was given
the prayer of father in heaven
and he give this prayer and then what he
say he didn't say in the name of jesus
christ what do you say he said i mean
that's what we do after prayer when we
do we say i mean
yeah that's it that's deep you know just
the lord's prayer if you as
as somebody who's trying to connect with
god let's say your background is
christianity
and you look at what you said the first
commandment
is that you shall have no other gods
except the one god and you won't worship
anything in the heavens
so what can that that can be stars
nature i mean the stars the sun
anything the birds the sun the ending
the angels the anything the people
worship these days you know anything
they see
and then it continues on nothing in the
sea nothing in the sea doesn't mean the
fishes like i saw sometime
i think the jehovah witnesses or baptist
people they put the fish in this
represented jesus
how will this represent the jesus if the
second commandment says do not
make the idols and this is explaining
the fish is true this is the word over
there
yeah i don't know and then also nothing
in the earth
nothing in the earth that's the first
commandment of course
you know nothing in the earth so i don't
know why people don't follow it like i
think they just blindly follow the
churches and they don't even open the
bible
because when i was a christian this what
threw me off when i actually opened the
bible and read it
i saw everything what they do in the
church this opposite of bible teach
this opposite of what jesus was teaching
the jesus come and say god is alpha and
omega
i don't do nothing except from his will
so anything miracle and anything he did
is because allah
the god almighty allow him to and he
says you know i'm human how many times
in the bible he's supposed to say i'm
human
and this is a scripture in the bible
says that god
is not a human he never born he never
died he's eternal
so don't you feel this contradiction if
he says i'm a human and god says in the
bible i'm not a human
i can't die and i cannot born so why you
guys just
blindly follow it and just close your
eyes on the scriptures
you made another interesting observation
about him making gusso
evolution before prayer so yeah what
they say he was a baptized no he wasn't
every time uh where we okay if he was
do the baptized why after that he go to
the grave and start uh worship the god
to teach you how to pray
why this is exactly what i'm explaining
when we
uh go into the masjid every friday we
doing
so this is me take a shower we
completely wash our uh
selves you know what i mean prepare to
the prayer put a clean clothes and we go
worship that's what we do you know on my
knees pray straight down we pray so this
is what exactly he did
he did the ghost after that he go to the
grave and he
uh showed the people how to worship the
god almighty
this is in the bible this is in the
bible yeah
they thought he was a baptized you know
what i mean and like okay if he was a
baptist whereas there was the cross
wasn't there and all this where is this
innovation all come from
jesus teach the people to wearing the
cross to worshiping this cross
to tell them if i die you guys need to
follow that and that and that
you know what i mean like i i don't know
where's all this come from there's not
in the bible for sure
so so the main point here was trying to
get people
because obviously we love jesus as a
mighty messenger
and we love our brothers and sisters in
humanities that's what we're sharing
this message
and is to direct their worship to the
one that jesus worshiped
simple so instead of worshiping jesus
worship the one jesus worship
and there's a very very interesting
passage also
in the bible that talks about
i believe it's in the gospel of mark
where someone came to jesus because god
has certain attributes that he's the
all-knowing he doesn't
become born he doesn't die and this is a
famous uh
verse that we always quote from the
quran allah
the language has been preserved today
and we have it in the verbatim word of
god the quran
where god almighty is saying that he's
one
alone worthy of worship say he is god
the one and only the absolute the
eternal he begets not nor is he begotten
there's nothing comparable to him
so you remember this passage where they
came to jesus and said
asking when the day of judgment is and
he said why are you asking me
no one knows no no but god not angels
not humans not nobody knows
except allah only god knows so if he is
the son would you guys say or he's a god
what most of the christians believe how
he don't know the day yeah okay
the interesting thing i watched this
movie the passion of the christ
when the jesus was on the cross what he
was screaming
he was screaming allah allah in his
language
and he said did you forget about me so
he don't really know the plans of the
god and stuff like that so
i don't know why people confuse them
right yeah
this one uh before you even get to
talking about because this is this is
what you're gonna have to be looking
into
it's very simple and straightforward if
you are contemplating the purpose of
life
you want to know why you're here where
are you going when you die you're going
to have to follow the
blueprint that the creator sent now
which one which religion this person
making the claim this one that one when
you
when you boil it down you have islam and
you have christianity and if you're a
true christian
and you really want to follow the way of
jesus it's going to lead you actually to
submission to the will of the creator
now the creation islam
but now before people even get to that
we're even discussing this
a lot of times people they don't even
think about the purpose of life why
they're here
what do you like to tell them
for me when i was a christian i was
still
feeling a god person i always want to be
in a straight path
and i always have something in my heart
like i'm doing something wrong when i go
to the church and put the scandals to
these pictures you know what i mean this
wasn't
make sense to me when i can simply just
pray straight to the god
so i uh pray to the god you know cry all
night with my heart
and ask god to guide me please i read
the bible and read the quran
in the quran when you open the book of
the quran almost every ayat in the quran
talking to you
the god talking to you and he guide you
right over there when you with the pure
heart you want to be guided
you're going to be guided when you don't
want to be guided
you know when you're trying to find some
false you're not going to be guided
because even ayat in the quran right it
says
even if they want to find something
they're not going to find it but
i will increase their disease in their
hearts you know so
if you really want to find a straight
path just think about this look at the
jesus lifestyle
look at what he was preaching did they
the simple thing why people eating the
pork
the jesus himself eat the pork where he
says okay you guys can eat you tell me
about the
new testament how many people write the
book the bible
thousands and thousands of people you
know i mean the people who write the
new testament i don't think they even
walk or talk to the jesus christ or even
know somebody who knows him you know
what i mean
and how this is a new testament if this
was written way way way back in the days
there's not new testament yeah
in my opinion this is just a catholic
priest
write it down on their basement you know
i mean it's fact that we have uh
bible scholars that tell us that we
don't have a copy of a cop many people
think that matthew
wrote matthew luke wrote luke these were
the disciples of jesus but the the fact
is and
and we're never trying to offend anyone
in any religion these are just the facts
that
we don't know who bible scholars tell us
people of course call the gospel books
matthew mark luke and john
well they call it matthew mark luke and
john because we don't know who wrote
these books and there's no point calling
them sam fred jerry and harry i mean
they're they're written by people we
don't know who they were written by
they are anonymous you might not think
so because they have the title the
gospel according to matthew whoever put
that title on it was an
editor later the followers of jesus were
aramaic
speaking peasants from galilee lower
class men
who were not educated in fact
peter and john in acts chapter 4 verse
13 are literally said to be illiterate
they couldn't read and write of course
not they were fishermen they didn't go
to school
the vast majority of people in the
ancient world never learned to read
let alone write and their native
language was aramaic
these books are written in greek by
highly educated rhetorically trained
writers who are skilled in greek
composition instead
we don't have a copy of a copy of a copy
of a copy of a copy
of any original bible so now imagine i
give this example imagine that you're
driving
and we'll give two examples from this
you're driving and the police pull you
over
and now they go ahead and ask for your
license so you give them a copy
of a copy of a copy of something that's
not even a copy from your license
looks like it remnants of it would they
accept this no
but then it goes a little bit further
what if now
you had things marked off and things
were changed on that copy of a copy of a
copy of what's not even a copy of your
license
so this is what we have of today the
modern day bob that's not
that's not your fault i mean but now
people can go ahead
and invest further in that or look
beyond another example i give is
imagine if me and you are driving you
want to be the driver of me who's
driving this time
okay i'm driving so i ask you i'm
driving you're like eddie slow down and
i'm just like
and the police pull us over and they
give you a ticket exactly that's not
fair
does that be fair but that's the whole
thing and that's what people gravitate
to
in islam that you're responsible your
for yourself
you're not stained because someone did a
sin you know
adam to descend we have original
goodness what's your thought about that
being a former christian
now that now it's someone jesus because
the whole concept is that jesus had to
come die for your sins and exactly
okay just logically think about this
will you sacrifice your kid
why will you do this you're all mighty
god you're so powerful and you just want
to sacrifice your kid
to forgive your sins how does it make
sense all these have no
absolutely no logic to me and i'm
telling you this is a former christian
you know i don't offend nobody i was a
christian i'm born in a very
very religious family you know every
christmas we stay nights at the
church you know we follow all the
commandments and everything
but you know i find out this very
unlogical because now as a father having
the kids too
you know i mean you understand it's more
how like
come on man but i don't know it's just
confusing all this
and islam came god is not the author of
confusion so islam came
and a line of messengers you see every
messenger came with the same message pay
attention chronological order it makes
sense
easy to digest it doesn't have you doing
a bunch of mental gymnastics to make it
fit
god almighty created us and out of his
love he sent guidance and every
messenger came with the same message
worship the one god
worship the creator not his creation and
they came with the blueprint for life
the purpose of life
now we're sending this message to our
dear friend
john jones bone did you see what was
your what was your take
and when you saw the after his fight we
know habib
he
that means it's like saying hallelujah
right like all praise to the creator
and then he prostrates like jesus did
praying to the god jesus did but then it
was interesting
jon jones finishes his fight did you see
what do you say
he said oh man
that is so good how are you doing oh man
[Music]
that is so good he said
manager at the gym if he really said it
and he said to me yes he did say this to
support all the brothers in the world
that's what he said to him so this was
nice you know that was nice thank you
john jones now
we're reciprocating more love because i
i did a
we did a video not too long ago after he
did this and we broke it down
we'll leave that one also so people can
actually see what is the meaning behind
it and when you know the meaning
i'll give i'll make it even easier for
them and i'll go back
to the bible you know in the gospel of
matthew when one came to jesus
and he said oh good master what good
thing can i do he's coming to jesus
what good thing can i do that i might
have eternal life i mean how do i get to
paradise
and jesus it's like me coming say adi
kedakov man you're so tough you're so
strong this isn't it he said
he said alhamdulillah right so you're
shifting you see a lot of fighters they
do this kind of stuff
you're shifting it so this is what he
was doing jesus he's shifting it he says
he's saying alhamdulillah say why are
you calling me good there's none good
but god what do you got to say about
that that's deep huh
in every point and aspect of his life he
was proven that god is only one and
worship him
every message he was sent he said that
god is the only one to worship him he
never says worship me
a lot of people tell me but he called my
father i say okay when you go into the
catholic church what do you call a
priest over there you call him a father
so you call him a father not because
he's your physical father because he's
your
spiritual father the god is a spiritual
father for all of us he created us all
so this is what he was mean think about
that
and alhamdulillah he got us all if you
go and look
every uh start from the atom
and down to the jesus in the bible every
prophet will talk about the
god is one every one of them and as soon
as you get to the
new testament the people we don't know
who is after us of this
they start this trinity thing going on
over there yeah that's correct right
but if you look at the every prophet who
was in the bible there was talk about
the god is one
and the people who it doesn't do nothing
with jesus or nobody
they start this trinity in this
mythology yeah when you look into the
history you look at the uh
the true followers of jesus they
preached a pure monotheism
uh calling people to worship the one god
as time went on
you had the the mixture coming into
collectively with the pagan rituals of
many of the greek gods and they already
had the trinity
and mixed up and now to kind of you know
intertwine make this
fit now you have what's developed today
far away from the pure monotheism so jon
jones bones
you know appreciating you know and we're
giving that love back
so having him think people someone like
him you know
people this resonates if you're sincere
and you're really thinking not turning
off
your thinking cap putting it on this
just makes sense it goes what we call
the fitra the natural inclination inside
every human being
right so what else would you say if you
had a one-on-one conversation with jon
jones
and we're doing this out of the love for
him his fans and everybody out there you
got to be sincere you got to be
genuinely searching for the truth and a
lot of times it's hard because you have
an emotional attachment to this
so what do you what would you say to jon
jones bones
coming from ali kedakar former
professional fighter
yeah i will teach him about islam tell
them the purpose of this life we're not
here just being like an animals to
eat you know sleep and repeat
wait wait to eat sleep and repeat rinse
wash and again the cycle goes for that
you always have to think about it you're
telling me you believe in god but don't
you believe there's going to be life
after
and you believe you have purpose to
deserve everybody telling me to when i
talk to people oh if god so good why he
don't put us all
in the paradise okay i say the first
place when you want to become a doctor
how many years does it take to become a
doctor you know
you go through the test you go through
the exams and then you become a doctor
it's not just they give it to you and go
he will be manic to murdering people
over there you know with a scalpel
but the same with the paradise the only
clean people can enter do you imagine
the child molesters the murderers you
know all these bad people will be with
you over there
do you think they deserved it you know
this way you have to go through the test
through this life there's so much fit
now now you know so much stuff in this
world even our iphones our phones how
much stuff over there you know what i
mean we have to go through every day
you're passing your and the word jihad
with a lot of people don't understand
what the mike tyson when he became a
muslim he'd say he learned
jihad he's fighting your own desires
you're finding yours every day if you're
a merry man you don't look to the other
woman you don't swear you don't drink
alcohol you don't do drugs
you know what i mean this is the jihad
you're finding your own desires
this is the main point of our life we
find our own desires so when we meet
creator
we can have our head up and we say we
made it alhamdulillah we made it you
know what i mean
another way when you don't made it
you're going to put your head down and
you can say nothing because god tell you
i send you a messenger and the messenger
and the messenger i give you the book
and i give you all the opportunities
to follow it what's your problem this is
what we're going to say what are you
going to say what we're going to say
when you especially now you're talking
to jon jones the bones
and you ask him like what do these
people have in common
kunta kinte what is malcolm x
what is muhammad ali let's start with
they all have the same roots and when
the african americans
go to their roots like kunta kinte i
mean
30 plus at 30 percent
of the african americans who were
brought here unjustly on the atlantic
trade
ships they were actually muslim
kunta kente was saying allah malcolm x
went back to his roots
and he's a muslim one who submitted to
the will of god america's hero you see
it in the gym you see muhammad ali
people be wearing his shirt but they
forget and then many people have this
hatred
because of all the media hype and all
the lies they've been told
they hate muslims but they're wearing
muhammad ali on their shirts
right first of all i want to thank
almighty god
allah for you all
thank god for my talent all the praise
that we're getting
so they were muslims all what they have
in common they were ones who
opened their minds they did the research
and they went back to their roots so
what would you
and telling john jones bones to go back
to your roots and that would be islam
exactly go back to your roots like he's
changed his name kasich clay because he
said this was my slave master name you
know my name was
muhammad ali and this is why he back in
the days the black people were the
rulers there was a kings and the queens
they have a big beautiful history
that's deep you know it was about an
islam and
allah raised you up so high you know
what i mean you have everything
but then they brought you in the boats
over here and they just start your uh
history from that and what amazed me the
people just don't want to go back they
agree with that john jones listen to
this this is profound listen
listen yeah you just agree with starting
your uh
history from the bones you go look at
your slave master i see some
documentaries look why you cares about
this part this part was did on you and
justin
look at the judgment your grand grand
grandparents were the kings and the
queens and the rulers
he's saying that look at that i
understand that african americans back
then when before they brought they were
kings queens they had in civilization
and that was all taken from them yeah
and you know what i mean you have a
beautiful history and what what what
make you be so
special you guys always muslims and now
you pull out
the church and i don't know how to put
this the right way
you know like a mormons an example right
they thought the black skin is a curse
okay and people still keep going to this
church
you know i don't want to offend nobody
like i say but i'm just give you the
facts
then like all the angels are white
the jesus was uh drawn up this is what
muhammad ali was saying this is what he
was thinking is the words of muhammad
ali that's what he say
he's sitting with his mom and his mom
asked his mom mom did we gonna make to
the parent that she said why
she said because everything is white and
everything black is bad black cat is
back
black duck in this story you know
he's thinking he's a thinking man he was
elected he was a little kid and this is
what he have in his mind
to talk with his mom you know what i'm
because that's what he was seeing the
church
only see hate to the black and see all
pure and white you know what i mean and
then he said do you sure we're going to
make to the
paradise and she said yes probably we'll
make and he said what we're going to do
serve in the kitchen
we're going to serve in the kitchen so
subhanallah you know what i mean you
can't do because we all created from
the god uh you know the hadith of the
when the gods get the
different type of earth from the earth
yes yes so get up a different type of
earth you know this was a black earth
and all this type of different colors of
the earth and he created adam
and this is how we all have a different
different shades and colors but
most importantly it's over here is the
heart the guy don't look at your skin
color
you don't look at your position he don't
look you're a president you're mma
fighter you're a champion he look what
in your heart
you have to be pure and sincere with
your god and don't don't just worry
about now
who's on the winning team you know
because the people who are following
jesus his true followers they were
muslims and they were persecuted and
this is what you have going on today
with the muslims so now
that's the biggest test the biggest test
is now when the truth comes to you
penetrates you're like you have those
you know people say certain things and
it just clicks
and you know if you're sincere this
clicks the worship of one god
not three in one not someone dying for
your sins you're responsible for
yourself these examples
he's given and makes sense and now the
message is coming to you are you
courageous enough or you say oh the
muslims are not on the winning team
right now
right it's not cool to be muslim you're
going to wait for that what are you
going to say
to your creator then the things i want
to say i always go to different churches
okay if everybody united them why they
have a korean even asians korean church
some other church you know haitian
church asian church different
jamaica church jamaican church haitian
church you know what i mean different
type of churches
and people focus or when you talk to
them they say oh jesus was black
oh no jesus was white oh no jesus this
was we muslims we focus not on his skin
color we focus on his teachings
not on his not on his skin color but his
teachings exactly
what he got the pure monotheism exactly
he came with the god is one
worship him alone alone yeah you know
what i mean he came with this message to
us and this what we as a muslims we're
following
if he will come to the earth just think
of thought
right now and he will see the muslims
and he will see the christians
he don't know who and what but just the
look i guarantee he will choose the
muslims and i'll give you
uh why the muslims grow the beard like
them we don't need the pork like him
we were circumcised like him we dressed
like him the mother mary
all our woman's dressed like her wearing
this car hijab mary was in hijab so
visually he just look he will think this
is my followers you know what i mean
when he looked at the woman who's a
short scarf half naked
a man with a shaved face wearing the big
crows up here so you
made a really great point that jesus
came
here today he'd probably get stopped by
the tsa
because he would look like a muslim and
remember guys don't get caught up with
the words muslim is one
who has consciously chosen to submit to
the will of the creator that's what a
muslim look up these definitions that's
what the jesus says in the bible
i submit to the god and he say you're
all willing to submit to the god
but this is what it is that's what it is
submission we submit to the god yeah
just don't play with the words and don't
be scared of arabic you know what i mean
like
okay in the bible they trust okay let's
go back to his name jesus right his name
is issue right it wasn't yeah
yeah what was it again tell him you know
what i mean so
his real name is issue so they
completely change all the names i'm
pretty sure the disciples and the people
who were amongst them in the bible they
changed the name too
they say moses his name wasn't moses his
name was musa
you know what i mean so with other old
you know because they change it
i don't know like you know back in this
when i was christian my people tell me
why you accept the arabic
religion i say okay why you accept the
jewish religion do you
think he was a satan or something he was
russian no he wasn't man
so this is you know my point don't be
scared of the word just
stick to the translation translate the
word and see what this means
you know what i mean and i agree i
guarantee you're going to agree with it
that's right jon jones and we appreciate
that you came out he said alhamdulillah
and you said when you called his coach
he said remind us again the manager of
the gym why he did that
he did this to support all the brothers
in the world to support all the other
the muslim fighters in the world
and now we're going ahead and send some
love his way to john jones and invite
him give him an invitation
and send him something to think about
all right and this is never again you
didn't see us insulting anybody
we're not putting nobody down we're just
stating some some obvious facts
we're inviting people to think and to
ponder giving
also the the islamic position on jesus
that really resonates and makes sense
for the thinking person and before we
conclude
what else would you say to there was a
i i mentioned i forgot we mentioned the
lord's prayer you know this also has
that prayer it's so so connected so
similar to the al-fatiha the opening
chapter of the quran where
oh our father who are in heaven so you
could just change us or our lord
or our lord who art in heaven hallowed
be thy name thy kingdom come that means
everything belongs to the creator
thy will be done that's islam right
there yes yes
that's what islam is exactly so
if you're reading the the lord's prayer
right there that's a direct connection
are you praying to jesus in this lord's
prayer no you pray directly to the god
to all one and only you know what i mean
yeah
do you do you think that do you think
people like jon jones when they
you know when people hear if you're
sincere and you hear the
simple message clear because people get
stuck you know trinity and
you know it doesn't make sense and and
they try to make it fit and now here
comes
the truth the pure monotheism one god
leave it alone hero israel the lord thy
god
is one jesus could have been like
expounding on
three and me and the father and the holy
gho he didn't do that he just said
one so now when he hears this this fits
this just it
fits if you're sincere why do you think
people back away they still again we
talked about winning team and everything
what what in your experience
what does it think i think brother like
back in the days when the moses
can you imagine moses just brought the
people through the ocean
he opened the ocean right in front of
them it's a huge miracle can you imagine
to see this with your eyes witness
something like that
you know i mean we don't see nothing we
just believe yeah but these people
witnessed something like this
and he when he go to the mountain to
reveal uh
from the gather 10 commandments what
they did they built the boom
to worship him so in my opinion would
the christians get confused they need to
see something to worship it
to believe in it that's why they have
all these pictures
and they come and they worship to these
pictures they ask
through these pictures to the god the
same with the prayer when they pray
they say the god the jesus is the lord
right and why you pray to the god
and then you mention through the jesus
christ you know you say oh in the name
of
jesus christ so the same pictures over
here when you go to these pictures
you pray to the god but through them but
what did jesus say
pray to the one god pray the lord my
lord and your lord
you know i mean that's what he's look at
that's important to jesus said to my god
and your god
yeah this is what he's saying the bible
yeah he said this is uh
we go on and on and i i don't want to um
continue on too much
we covered a lot a lot to think about
and again
this has been something that done out of
the love and at the end if a person
chooses
to go ahead and continue on that way i
mean we still i mean
this is simple you know we want
something good for you just like receive
the gift you know
we have we have a the hadith when the
private citizens
says you're never going to enter the
paradise if you don't want something for
your brother what you want for yourself
i want to get to the paradise i want for
you to get to the paradise this was
sharing the message you accepted or not
but we don't put anybody down we love
people that's why we're doing this
wow think about that they're trying to
take the person tries to take you to the
club to the party
and and get you ahead of the line and
buy you drinks and hang out and
and that actually ends up being like
your your worst nightmare of a friend
right you follow that person and you're
going in the wrong way right
but now you're happy like that's my
buddy but now you got your bro
your brother and humanity ali kedakov
out of his love he's trying to
hold your hand and get your agenda to
paradise so people shouldn't you know
because a lot of times people take
offense and get upset
you don't have to be offense because you
i speak auto i was a christian myself
you know and i i know the position of
the people when they misguided
or they read a lot of stuff on google
internet and they became
you know shakes and the scholars out to
the google real quick you know what i
mean i just want to share the message if
you really want to find the god
open the quran start studying and
clearly just pray to the god that
all one almighty and ask him to the
guidance and i guarantee you're gonna
guide you
i'm gonna guide you to the straight path
well uh
we promised we talked a little bit where
uh what was your favorite when you when
you were fighting you fought for over
what like 15 years
yeah even more more right professional
fighter
left it retired what what was your what
was your favorite uh technique in the
ring
things what would you like to do more on
stand up right hook
take them down i like to kick people in
the head
you'd like to go for the the crow cop
kick to the head because i love
crocodile back in the day
yeah it was my favorite actually yeah
well that's what we have we're ending it
here with
ali kedokov here on the dean show and
inshallah help us get this message to
john jones the bones that how you say
john jones the bones yeah and if he
wants to hook up with you
if he wants to connect where can he find
you american top team
yeah if he's in floyd does he visit i
don't think he visits but maybe well you
got your brother yeah one of his friends
romero
he's from our team he's trained with him
okay so now you got two you got two of
you pretend you got your brothers here
you can visit if you're in chicago
look us up this is the place you want to
go there my man yeah we'll hook you up
there and then if you're in florida hook
up with our brother ali kedokov and
for the rest of you subscribe and tune
in every week here to the d show leave
your comments and some of the gems you
picked up on
share them with us we'll see you next
time here on the dean show god willing
peace be with you salaam alaikum
peace and love